größer sein
ok
versteht mich auf dieses match wird
eigentlich macht mir am meisten spaß
wenn ich dann so in den probenraum stehe
und dann singe ich mit mehr wähler zu
sagen so singen so einfach so thöne
das war ganz früh ich glaube ich
beziehen und kleber 22 mir räder wann
genau sie war die älteste super peinlich
sparen bisschen schüchtern war
stehen
eigentlich habe ich da noch nie darüber
geredet aber nein diese tatsächlich
nicht echt wir haben leider alle eine
nadel
wenn mir herab journal sieht die rente
du hast nur du hast ja nur bei michaela
mag ich ganz gerne das glühbirne weil
immer wenn sie eine gute idee hat das
ist echt geil immer wenn sie gute idee
hat kommt sie an
also der tanz der ist so exklusiv ja mal
geprobt und dann habe ich mir gesagt nee
nicht mehr alle ich habe nie gesagt dass
ich spinne gefragt wo ist die spinne
spinne tot money in the bank
herr wie wir machen hat er demnach ich
verstehe irgendwie gerade die frage mich
wir machen doch wir sind doch der ifa
daten nach machen
wir sind ja der tiefer ins an rap das
ist ja nicht also gibt parallelen klar
dass mir jetzt irgendwie auch zu retten
ein bisschen immer dieses ganze riege
fragen mit einem schal
lacaba kam raus kommst du